hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i want to talk about how
do you stay motivated to pick up the
phone book viewings because it can be
really hard to get yourself psyched up
give yourself the willpower to actually
do what you know needs to be done in
property this is not just the case
people starting out i've got so many
students that are making two grand three
grand a month and then they get
comfortable and lose the momentum and
lose the um that sort of willpower they
need to motivate themselves to pick up
the phone and keep going keep going keep
going so i've got three suggestions for
you in this video you might want to take
notes and this will really help you to
be self-motivated in any business but
i'm particularly talking about the
property business right now if you enjoy
my youtube channel please do me a
massive favor smash the like button it
literally costs you nothing to do that
so go ahead smash the like button also
subscribe to the channel and turn on the
notification bell so you do not miss and
upload so first way to stay motivated is
you need to have a very clear
reason for why you're doing what you're
doing let's say you want to make two
grand a month and you get through
property and your strategy is rent to
rent or you want to be a deal sourcer
and you want to leave your job and
package and sell one deal a month how do
you get the motivation to pick up the
phone to agents
go to the networking events and do what
needs to be done well rather than
thinking about what you want to achieve
which is financial freedom which is to
leave your job rather than think about
that think about why
you want to achieve it so it might be
that you want a nicer house maybe you
want a nicer car maybe you want to get
out of your job because you hate it so
what i would suggest doing is
think about if you achieve your goal
how will that affect your life what will
life look like visualize it get a
picture of it and literally turn that
into a physical picture which we call
your dream board so you've got your
dream board with your dream car your
dream house your dream life your dream
holiday all the people you want to have
all the people you want to inspire and
get a visual dream board have that print
it off and have it in your uh
in your lounge or in your bedroom so you
see it all the time and then that way
when you're thinking i can't be bothered
to pick up the phone
you've got that dream board which is
like hang on a minute
that's the reason why this is why i'm
doing so that's the first thing point
number two is
make sure that you hang around with
people that are doing what you want to
do so if you want to make three grand a
month in property
how many people are you currently
hanging around with that are doing that
if the answer is zero then you need to
increase the number by five the five
people that you spend the most time with
will you will make up the person that
you are if you want to be a property
developer if you want to do
land deals or lease options or house
flipping then you need to make sure that
you find other people that are doing
that we call this positive peer pressure
if you're hanging around
um people that are making
1500 a month working in retail and
you're doing the same nothing wrong with
that but that will be what's acceptable
and normal to you and what you accept is
what you become so make sure point
number two that you're hanging around
other people that are constantly pushing
you up and pulling you up and inspiring
you to be more and then number three and
this is my favorite by the way if you
enjoyed the video don't forget to hit
like number three is
hold yourself
accountable in the same way that you
would hold an employee accountable if
you are running your own business you
are effectively an employee
in your own company so what you should
do is and um every week you say right
what am i going to do this week we do
something called plan do review okay so
plan what am i going to do this week
what needs to be done right write it
down
then go and do it
but then at the end of the week review
what you did so have an accountability
meeting with yourself and say right this
is what i said i was going to do did i
do it and sit down book it in your
direct half an hour a week
accountability meeting did you do what
you said you were going to do that week
every monday morning and every friday
afternoon you've got a monday morning
meeting with yourself
to plan out what you're going to do that
week and then on friday friday at 5 00
pm a meeting with yourself half an hour
did you do it and if you didn't do it
then you need to hold yourself account
as you would hold an employee account
sometimes people say i'm really
struggling with my business i'm like
well that's because
you suck i mean if you were my employee
i would fire you and if you were your
own employee you would probably fire
yourself so if you would fire yourself
from your own company then you need to
grip so accountability if you're running
your own business you're not going to
have a boss holding you account it's
your business so you need to become your
own boss hold yourself account so to
recap set goals have a dream board
surround yourself with people that are
going to pull you up and inspire you and
number three hold yourself account every
single week if you do those three things
you will have no issue with with being
motivated you will get it done so the
only thing you might be missing now is
knowing what to do and that is why i
think it's really important that you get
trained the more you learn the more you
earn so i am going to be giving away
free tickets to a upcoming training
program with myself and if you want to
come down and you want to learn all
things property then i'm going to leave
a link in the description i'm giving
away free tickets limited limited
availability so get a book now don't
forget as well subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time